it's a toss-up my wife is the greatest
dining companion and
you know a total joy to cook for and
she's a good eater and I really have fun
together but I have to say that my kids
who grew up eating my food and can call
and say I'm coming over could you make
something Asian or I'm coming over i
need this pasta dish or I'm coming over
and could you just could we have one of
those you know I it's really nice i mean
like you're grown there's a lot of
history there and it's it's really
special to cook for that i don't have to
convince anybody that what i'm making is
good I know it's good I usually enjoy it
if someone enjoys eating they'll enjoy
eating this stuff I cook if they don't
something's wrong somewhere you know
there's not you know Julia Child used to
say the great thing about cooking is you
get to eat your mistakes the thing is
that if you take care and cooking and if
you know what you're doing even a little
bit unless you burn something there are
very few things that wind up so bad that
you can't enjoy them very few so I mean
and I you know I'm lucky enough to have
been doing this long enough and writing
about it and learning from other people
and thinking about so that generally
speaking the stuff I do is pretty good
the people I cook for tend to enjoy it
but I said before it's not it's not
brilliant it's not earth-shattering it's
just good food
temari and I have known each other
probably 10 years and we've gotten
increasingly busy so we don't see each
other that much so it was really a treat
to hang out so much and um I I know from
my the people who I was going to say my
fans which I guess is right but anyway I
know from people who've watched Spain on
the road again and my other TV shows
that everybody thinks that TV is the
most fun thing in the world and
everybody is completely jealous of whoa
well you've got to hang out with Mario
and Gwyneth and this who is that
beautiful woman and the food and Spain
must be so amazing fact this television
is a tremendous amount of work and for
every minute on screen there's an hour
of work so for every 60 minutes on
screen there's a week of work and it
really is like that so we did a huge
amount of driving and there's a lot of
set-up time and not exactly rehearsal
but figuring out what we're going to do
so none of that was my favorite part my
favorite part was nighttime when
everything was done and we all got drunk
together so that was really great and
Mario's Mario of course can drink anyone
under the table I think he'll admit to
this um a mean it's not an admission I
think he'll be proud of this whereas I
can't drink anyone under the table plus
i go to bed earlier than anybody else i
go to bed earlier than anybody so we'd
finish the shoot we'd have a bite eat
we'd have a fair amount of wine it would
be 930 1030-1130 I'd go to bed Mario be
up till four in the morning everyone
else was waking up with black eyes and
broken shoulders he was always in great
shape so that was sort of fun it was
like
so I could say I would cook for Adolf
Hitler and serve him poison I could say
that I could say quite sincerely see I
don't think you can influence people
really i mean i like the obvious answer
and obvious answers i well i would cook
for president obama and set him straight
on a number of issues but he's already
got a lot of people setting him straight
I think the people I'd most like to cook
for would be my maternal grandparents
who I loved very much it have been dead
a long time and who I think in some ways
were responsible a lot for my
personality and a lot for the way I
handle myself and also for my love of
food and saying that makes me think I
should go cook for my parents more often
than I do they're alive fortunately so
I'm going to go